i feel like a [ __ ] stuck
in this duck it makes me wanna quack
like what the [ __ ] is that oh oh there
you're gonna make a tower make a tower
go left yes that's right
that's right that's not right you caught
that right robin
no no no
until you oh
hello my name is pedophile
please don't kill me someone's hands out
of the wall
hello hey tickle each other oh give me a
oh there you go no hugs for you
no for you beauty took hold of christ's
hand
before he could protest
i had a feeling i could be happier
with you i don't know if you even like
me
i don't know if you even like
oh no way there's a brain in there oh
man this
oh i i done
nope okay don't worry it's just the game
games can't hurt okay we're dead
this one goes out to all you bros out
there
it's hard to believe that i couldn't see
you were always there beside me
oh [ __ ] bros i think he's oh [ __ ] he's
running what are you doing
what okay we can actually do this [ __ ]
oh my god
oh don't you dare bleed on me bob i will
[ __ ] kill you if you died
hey how's it going guys you look so
conceited
i'm just pleased to be here [ __ ] you
brian
oh my god
damn
i am a prostitute why would i become of
something
okay i am a toy thanks game
you are the most beautiful dog they call
you
jabba their heart jabba their heart
for a reason
sorry about that there we go i choose
you
pikachu why the hell did that not work
don't look at me like that you guys
wouldn't what the [ __ ] are you two doing
stop i may have test but that's
offensive
it's like yeah what you want look at me
peers
what are you doing don't don't no don't
fan your penis
walk with high heels chew up gum and
speak
french
oh i can stick it up his butt perfect or
battles but
i i what do you what the [ __ ] are you it
works
what are you cooking is that for me
oh that what what oh it became longer
there's a [ __ ] tomahawk
okay you might feel a little headache
bob
but that's normal tomahawk chop
top
it was going so well
i can't see [ __ ]
what
you thought you got a big
oh no it's coming oh no let me save you
i will
what the [ __ ] was that i don't even what
is going on here
what do you want did you just touch me
do it again please i loved it no don't
don't
it's a joke don't you understand a joke
no
twerk for
oh what the [ __ ]
no way in hell
no no
no no no
i give up do you have an experience with
pink toaster violence if you do
be a tree well luckily i never had any
oh
[ __ ]
that's not me nice ben you're playing
bro yay
hey hand hug no handheld oh wait
to whoever is watching this video close
your eyes for 10 seconds
and let your imagination flow close them
now
yes that would be a good idea because i
i don't [ __ ] me uh
what parkour video that guy's handsome
who's that
what we and me and bob had it was
something you see once in a lifetime
bob was one of those guys you can just
go out and have a beer with
and make out a little bit with and it
wouldn't be awkward the day after
bob was that guy he would actually touch
my butt a lot
and it would tickle in the nicest way
bob knew how to treat me like a princess
we are alive never mind never mind i'll
find
someone like you
reenact gandalfs you shall not pass a
scene
you shall not pass
be careful run you fools
i am back gandalf how did you i'm a
wizard
wait why was i on that bench
what in the heavens no holy sh
holy [ __ ] i can't fap i
catch fab i can't
hope you bros enjoyed this montage if
you did
be sure to leave a like and a favorite
it will help me out a lot
also be sure to share this video with
someone maybe your dog
maybe your grandma or maybe even your
friends
last montage we did we had 2.5 million
subscribers or bros
now we are at 8 million which is just
crazy
and i want to thank you all for being
subscribed i wouldn't even be making
these videos if it wasn't for you
if you aren't subscribed already be sure
to do so now this annotation will open
a new window for you click here to watch
another montage
all the original videos are linked in
the description and as always
here comes the brofist
you